[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض ونشدو معكم ابرز المستجدات
وفي العناوين
عشره قتلى في تركيا وسوريا جراء زلزال
الاخير وتقارير عن اشخاص عالقين تحت
الانقاض في هاتاي
بايدن في بولندا بعد زيارته السريه الى
كييف وخطاب مرتقب لبوتين في ذكرى بدء
الحرب
مناورات بحريه روسيه صينيه مرتقبه في جنوب
افريقيا ودول غربيه تعرب عن قلقها
منظمه حقوقيه تطالب ايران بالغاء احكام
اعدام ضد سته شبان وتصفها بغير العادله
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا ضرب زلزالات جديدان
وهناك عالقون جدد ايضا في المنطقه
الحدوديه بين تركيا وسوريا خلف حتى الان
كما اعاد الرعب بل كما اعاد الرعب الى
قلوب ما لبثت تهدا بعد اسبوعين فقط من
وقوع زلزال المدمر الذي قتل اكثر من 47
الف شخص والحق ادرارا بمئات الالاف من
المنازل في البلدين حيث افاد براس عربي
بسقوط سته قتلى في تركيا وعشرات الاصابات
وكان نائب رئيس التركي فؤاد افاد قبل ذلك
باصابه ثمانيه اشخاص في انهيار مباني
متصدعه اما في سوريا مشاهدينا فقد افادت
وكاله الانباء الرسميه سانا بوصول سبعه بل
47 حاله الى مستشفى الرازي في حلب معظمها
ناتجه عن الهلع وحالات كسور وردود جراء
التدافع ومن جهتها افادت منظمه القوات
البيضاء بتسجيل اكثر من 130 اصابه في شمال
غربي سوريا
التركيه المنكوبه مشاهدينا تحولت ليلا بعد
زلزال الاخير الى مدينه اشباح خصوصا مع
توقف اليات فرق الانقاذ عن العمل الظلام
والسكون يخيمان على المدينه موفد العربي
قد خربوش رفض الوضع في المدينه بعد ساعات
من الزلزال الاخير نتابع
هذه واحده من الاف البنايات التي
تحطمت جراء زلزال القوي الذي ضرب المنطقه
الجنوبيه لتركيا مثل ما تشاهدون اغراض
ومقتنيات سكان هذه الاحياء لا تزال على
حالها ولا ندري اين هم من كانوا يملاون
هذه الاحياء بالحياه الاطفال
الرجال النساء منهم من فارق الحياه ومنهم
من غادر المكان ومنهم من وجد نفسه الان
يلتحف السماء في خيمه باقل الامكانيات
السكون الصمت هو وحده من يسكن هذه الاحياء
الان لكن الهزات الارتداديه التي اضحت
قويه وتحولت الى زلازل هي وحدها من تكسر
هذا السكون
لتبدا هذه البنايات الايه للسقوط في اي
لحظه
بالتصدع مجددا ونسمع بين الفينه والاخرى
سقوط اجزاء من هذه البنايات ما يدفعنا الى
الرحيل باقصى سرعه من هذا المكان عبد
القادر خربوش لقناتي العربيه والحدث من
مدينه هاتاي جنوب تركيا هذا وثقت
الكاميرات اللحظات الاولى لوقوع زلزال امس
الاثنين في مطارها تاي حيث اظهر الفيديو
حاله من الرعب عاشها المسافرون
والمتواجدون في المطار ومحاوله احتمائهم
بكراس الانتظار خوفا من الزلزال الذي بلغت
قوته 6 درجات فاصله اربعه على مقياس ريختر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
القتاليه لرصد اثار الزلزال والدمار
اللاحق بالمباني في مدينه هاتاي جنوب
تركيا
[موسيقى]
منها تايم مشاهدينا ينضم الينا العربيه
عبد القادر
وكيف يمكن وصف تداعيات هاتين الهزتين يوم
امس
بالخوف والهلع المتواصل لدى الناجين من
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب المنطقه ومن
يقطنون الان في هذه الخيم الاستعجاليه
التي نصبت بهذه الحديقه وسط مدينه هاتاي
تعدادها
270 خيمه تاوي عدد كبير من الناجين اذا
فيك تحكي عربي نسالك كيف كيف عايشين بها
الخيام كثير صعب ما في كهرباء ما في
17 18 يوم على حالتنا والبارح ضرب زلزال
قوي كمان
سته ونقطه اربع سنوات وبعدين صارت حسيته
يعني عندك اصابه هذه امبارح
معك
عيالنا والله كتير يعني صعبه بنعيش وبرضو
مطر
هاي الموضوع متى يمكن ان تصمدوا في هذه
الخيام والله يا اخي كثير صعب الله لا
يوقع حدا كتير كتير صعب اللي بعيش بيعرف
لكن في مساعدات توصلكم على الاقل الاكل
ساخن وكل شيء الاكل
من الساعه خمسه اكثر من 50 مره تفكر في
المستقبل القريب او البعيد كيف ستكون
الحياه كذب
هذه المخيمات حول ما جرى او مسلسل الرعب
المتجدد معهم في هذه المدينه المتعرضه
لهزات ارتداديه ثلاث حتى زلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب امس حوالي عشرين هزه هناك اليوم
قرار
بتحويل نحو 100 الف طالب من هذه المناطق
المتضرره نحو مناطق اخرى نشاهد الان هناك
بعض الاشخاص ربما يغادرون حتى هذه الخيام
التي مثل ما قلت سابقا ربما لا يشعرون
الان بامان في هذه المناطق ممكن اسالك
سنحاول ترجمه ما يقوله بمساعده احدث
منتقلين الى ولايه تانيه لماذا
هل تشعر بالخوف
بعد الزلزال الاخير ربما انتم تخوفتوا
تريدون المغادره
لكن هو يودي الاطفال
يعني تريد ان تنقذ اطفالك من هذه المدينه
انت متخوف انه بيصير شيء
نعم الف سلامه عليك يقول بانه يفر باطفاله
وعائلته الى مدينه اخرى بعيدا عن هاتاي
نشاهد وهو يحمل الان مقتنيات هؤلاء
الاطفال لكنه متشبت بارضه يقول بانه سيعود
الى هاتاي ويبقى هنا لمساعده المتضررين من
هذا الزلزال نشاهد
لي يعني اغلب منازل انطاكيا او بل هاتاي
بصوره عامه مدمره جزئيا او كليا لكن هناك
حديث عن بعض المنازل الصامته الصامته في
هذه الازمه هل استطاع سكانها العوده اليها
والمبيت فيها
قد يكون ذلك قبل ثلاثه ايام وقبل حدوث
الزلزال الكبير الذي ضرب امس المنطقه لكن
الان اكاد اجزم ان لا احد بداخل بيته على
الاقل هنا في حيث تجولت عده شوارع وعده
يعني احياء شاهدنا يعني كان هناك يعني شبه
مدينه اشباح سواء ليلا او حتى اليوم صباحا
لا وجود لاشخاص انا اول مره الان اقابل
اناس بهذا المخيم هناك هجران لهذه البيوت
فعلا هناك بعض العمارات تعد على الاصابع
تبدو كانها صامده ولكن بها تشققات وبها
سنشاهد من من هذا الجانب في عمارات هاي
عماره مثلا
بالوسط عماره غير مكتمله الانجاز
شاهدتها قبل قليل بها تصدعات لكن طبعا
الخبراء هم من سيقررون ان كانت صالحه
العيش ام لا نشاهد هذه الصوره الان وهو
ياخذ مرحبا هذه لعبه ابنك
صوره معبره جدا يعني هناك تشببت بالحياه
حتى وسط الدمار والزلزال والموت ورائحه
الموت التي تحيط بكل مكان هناك نوع من
التشبت بالحياه في كل مع كل مقابله نجريها
مع هؤلاء الناس مع كل مشهد نراه مع كل
اعمال تطوعيه ومحاولات لانقاذ من هم تحت
الانقاض وان حدث ذلك سيكون معجزه بعد كل
هذه المده الزلزال الذي ضرب بالامس قضى
على سته اشخاص للاسف
ولحد الان لم تعلن السلطات عن عدد
الموجودين تحت الانقاد ونحن نحاول او نبحث
عن اماكن ان كانت فيها انقاذ لحد الان لم
نلحظ ذلك لكن سنستمر في البحث حتى نتوصل
جراء هذين شكرا لك من اعطاك العربي عبد
القادر
شدد مهندسون معماريون ومدنيون على ان خطط
رئيس طيب اردوغان لاعاده الاعمار سريعا
بعد زلزال المدمر الذي ضرب بلاده تنذر
بوقوع كارثه اخرى ما لم يتم اعاده النظر
بعنايه في التخطيط الحضري وسلامه المباني
وتشير التقديرات الى ان تكلفه اعاده
البناء ستبلغ نحو خمسه وعشرين مليار دولار
في حين تشير توقعات اخرى الى انها اعلى من
ذلك بكثير السلطات التركيه مشاهدينا من
جانبه اكدت ان اكثر من 300 الف وحده في
اكثر من 100 الف مبنى بحاجه ماسي الهدم او
انهارت من اصل مليونين ونصف المليون مبنى
في جميع انحاء المنطقه
والله
وبالعوده الى الجدل الدائري حول التوقعات
التي تتحدث عن حدوث زلازل جديده لفت عالم
الزلازل الهولندي المثير للجدل فرانك
عبر تغريده نشرها بعد دقائق من وقوع زلزال
تركيا الجديد امس الاثنين لفت نظر متابعيه
لتغريده اخرى توقع فيها وقوع هزات جديده
في المنطقه قبل حدوثها بحوالي 40 ساعه
تقريبا حيث اعاد نشره تنبؤ الهيئه التي
يتبعها والتي جاء فيها تحذير حول احتماليه
حدوث نشاط جزاري اقوى في الفتره من
العشرين الى 22 من فبراير تقريبا كما كشف
تنبؤ الهيئه الذي اعاد نشره العالم
الهولندي انه من المحتمل ان تبلغ ذروه هذا
النشاط في يوم 22 من الشهر الجاري هذا
وكان العالم الهولندي تنبا بحدوث زلزال
تركيا قبل ثلاثه ايام من وقوعه فجر
الاثنين السادس من فبراير وظهر في فيديو
بعد وقوع زلزال باربعه ايام وتوقع فيه
حدوث هزه قويه كما تحدث عن امكانيه حدوث
زلزال يشمل مصر ولبنان ما اثار جدلا واسعا
في المنطقه
مشاهدينا اثار زلزال التدميريه في تركيا
في السادس من فبراير لم تطلبينيه التحتيه
والمباني السكنيه فحسب بل دمرت ايضا
الكثير من الكنوز التاريخيه والمواقع
الاثريه ومنها اقدم مسجد في تركيا المزيد
هذا هو مسجد حبيب نجار في مدينه انطاكيا
بولايه هاتاي جنوب تركيا اقدم مسجد في
تركيا ضمن حدودها الحاليه بناه المسلمون
سنه 638 ميلاديه وصمد 14 قرنا في وجه كل
الظروف والكوارث التي ضربت هذه المنطقه
لكنه تدمر بشكل كبير بفعل الزلزال الاخير
المئذنه وقبه المسجد وجزء من الفناء
الداخلي دمر السلطات التركيه اغلقت المسجد
خوفا من انهيارات جديده
كل المنطقه التاريخيه المحيطه بهذا المسجد
تعرضت لدمار كبير اسواق ومحال وفنادق تعود
لمئات السنين ضربها الزلزال بشكل عنيف
وحولها الى اثر بعد عين زيدان من مدينه
انطاكيا هاتاي نشاطنا مستمره مشاهدينا
وفيها بعد الفاصل
الصين تعرب عن قلقها من تصعيد الصراع في
اوكرانيا وتحذر من امكانيه خروج الامور عن
السيطره
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد في تطورات
الحرب الاوكرانيه عبر وزير خارجيه عن قلق
في اوكرانيا وامكانيه الخروج عن السيطره
مشددا على ان الصين اتخذت موقفا موضوعيا
ومحايدا تجاه الازمه واضاف جانجان رئيس
الصيني ذكر عده بل ذكر عده نقاط يجب على
المجتمع الدولي القيام بها معا لتخفيف
الوضع وحل الازمه
لقد مر ما يقرب من عام منذ التصعيد الكامل
للعزمه الاوكرانيه يراقب المجتمع الدولي
تطورات عن كثب وتشعر الصين بقلق عميق ازاء
تصاعد الصراع وامكانيه الخروج عن السيطره
منذ اندلاع الازمه اتخذت الصين لموقفا
موضوعيا ومحيدا
بخلاف القرارات السابقه القرار الذي ستصوت
عليه الجمعيه العام لامم المتحده في
الايام المقبله لا يدين العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه حسب ما افاد به الاثنين مصدران
دبلوماسيان فرنسيان لوكاله فرانس فمن
المتوقع ان تتبنى الجمعيه العامه المتحده
باغلبيه كبيره جدا الجمعه في ذكرى من على
بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا قرارا سيشكل دعوه
لانهاء النزاع وقالت مصادر الدبلوماسيه
فرنسيه لصحفيين انه على عكس الاختراعين
السابقين عدم ادانه روسيا بشكل قاطع بل
دعوتها لانهاء النزاع مؤكدا على ان هناك
رغبه في ترسيخ اجتماع بل ترسيخ اجماع دوري
على المعايير لتحقيق ذلك من المقرر
مشاهدينا ان يلقي الرئيس الروسي اليوم
خطاما امام نواب البرلماني واعضاء الحكومه
وذلك قبيل الذكرى السنويه الاولى لبدء
الحرب في اوكرانيا وبالتزامن ايضا مع مرور
سنه كامله على اعتراف موسكو باستقلال
جمهوريه دومباسك
خطاب بوتين في الحادي والعشرين من فبراير
2022 الماضيه مهدى لبدء اجتياح بري
لاوكرانيا يوم الرابع والعشرين من فبراير
اي بعد ثلاثه ايام من خطاب الاعتراف
قال مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي الذي
رافق الرئيسنا المسؤولين الامريكيين
ابلغوا نظرائهم الروس بان بايدن سيتوجه
الى كياف قبل بضع ساعات من مغادرته لاغراض
لعهد اغراض عدم تضارب وقال ان المرحله بل
ان الرحله تطلبت جهدا امنيا وعمليا من
المتخصصين في مختلف اداره الحكومه
الامريكيه للقيام بمهمه محفوفه بالمخاطر
بطبيعتها وعاقب زياره المرتقبه عاد بايدن
الى القطار في رحله وبعد وصوله الى هناك
شق طريقه الى وارسو التي وصلها ليل
الاثنين
هذا وافاد مساعد الرئيس البولندي بان رئيس
دودا سيطلب من بايدن زياده وجود قوات
النيتو في بولندا وكان رئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن قد وصل الى بولندا بعد زياره مفاجئه
حيث من المقرر ان يلتقي برئيس البولندي
اليوم الثلاثاء لمناقشه امدادته وتعزيز
قوه الردع لحلف الناتو حسب بيان سابق
للبيت الابيض هذا وفجاه الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن العالم بزياره غير معلنه مسبقا
الى العاصمه الاوكرانيه زياره سريه فتحت
باب التساؤل حول مسار رحله بعيد لكييف
المزيد في التقرير التالي
زياره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن للعاصمه
الاوكرانيه كييف تحمل الكثير في طياتها
فهي زياره الاولى له بعد ان اصبح رئيسا
للولايات المتحده وتتزامن مع قرب الذكرى
الاولى للحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا زياره
حملت معها الكثير من الاسئله خاصه انها
زياره غير معلنه ومفاجئه وجاءت بعد نفي
المتكرر من قبل مسؤولين امريكيين الرئيس
الامريكي شق طريقه لكيف في رحله سريه
لاسباب امنيه تم التخطيط لزياره حسب مواقع
مختصه بطلب من اوكرانيا وخطط لها باقل من
اسبوع استقل بايدن طائرته الرئاسيه من
قاعده اندروس في زياره قيل انها باتجاه
بولندا واقعيا دخل بايدن الاجواء
البولنديه الا انه غير مساره واستقل
القطار من بولندا باتجاه كييف في رحله
استغرقت قرابه 10 ساعات وسط حمايه لطائرات
امريكيه حربيه كانت تراقب المجال الجوي
الاوكراني زياره بايدن لم تكن سريه
بالنسبه لروسيا واشنطن نسقت مع كييف قبيل
الزياره لتجنب اي سوء تقدير يقود لمواجهه
زياره بايدن استمرت لقرابه خمس ساعات فقط
وبوفد دبلوماسي صغير تجول خلالها في شوارع
العاصمه كييف وزار جدار قتل الجيش
الاوكراني في الحرب وقدم خطابا في
البرلمان الاوكراني والتقى بعدد من
المسؤولين وقدموا وعودا لنظيره الاوكراني
بمزيد من الدعم العسكري والمادي زياره
بعيد لكييف حتى وان كانت سريعه اعتبرتها
اوكرانيا رساله انتصار وتحذيرا مبطنا
لموسكو
من قلب العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف تصريحات
ناريه للرئيس الامريكي
[موسيقى]
ثلث
نواس
[موسيقى]
في الرياضه
بعث رساله طمانه
الدعم مستمر وبزخم كبير
[موسيقى]
متى سيلقي الرئيس اذن بوتين خطابه اليوم
هل من تسريبات حول مضمون هذا الخطاب
مرحبا احمد نعم بالفعل صحيح ما تقول هو
خطاب عند الساعه الثانيه عشره بالتوقيت
المحلي اي بعد قرابه الساعه من الان طبعا
هذا الخطاب هو منتظر بشكل كبير بحيث ان
الرئيس بوتين يتوجه اليوم للمجلس
الفيدرالي للمره الاولى بعد اعلانه بدا
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وهذا الخطاب ياتي قبل
ثلاثه ايام على تاريخ مرور سنه على هذه
العمليه لذلك طبعا متوقع ان يكون الخطاب
موسع وبشكل كبير قد يستمر لساعات هذا
الخطاب
ويحضره طبعا وسيكون في القاعه كافه او
معظم اعضاء مجلس الشعب الروسي مجلس الشيوخ
نواب كثيرون وللمره الاولى سيحضر شخصيات
كان لها مشاركه في العمليه العسكريه روسيا
طبعا من المتوقع ان يقوم بوتين بتقييم هذه
العمليه وكيف تجري الاعمال القتاليه في
الجنوب وفي المناطق الاوكرانيه التي ضمتها
موسكو هذا الخطاب ياتي بعد يعني مد خارطه
روسيا كما يدور الحديث في الداخل حيث
اصبحت تضم اربع مناطق في الجنوب الاوكراني
داني سلوغانس خرسون
طبعا سيتطرقوا الى التحديث العسكري في
البلاد الى الوضع في الداخل الى قضيه
مواجهه العقوبات الغربيه والحديث عن الوضع
الداخلي في البلاد لذلك طبعا متوقع ان
يكون خطاب بوتين طويلا وقد يستمر لساعات
طيب متوقع ايضا ان يتضمن هذا الخطاب حديثا
حول الاوضاع الاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه في
البلاد ما الذي يامل الشعب الروسي او
الراي العام الروسي بصوره عامه بسماعه
اليوم
طبعا احمد يعني الحديث الدائر في البلاد
وعن المرجو من خطاب بوتين اليوم هو معرفه
وضعيه روسيا بشكل كبير سياسيا او اقتصاديا
طبعا ما يهم الوضع للمواطن الروسي اليوم
هو معرفه المرحله القادمه وما تخفيه طبعا
من اعمال عسكريه ان كانت فيها الاراضي
الاوكرانيه او الوضع الاقتصادي للبلاد
والتحديات الكبيره موسكو كانت قد التفت
نحو الشرق خلال العام الاخير نحو الصين
نحو الهند نحو الشرق او الاوسط وغيرها من
الدول المجاوره التي تدخل مع موسكو في
احلاف سياسيه او عسكريه وتعاون لذلك طبعا
ما يهم الشارع الروسي اليوم هو معرفه
الوضع الاقتصادي للبلاد الى اين سيصل
الروبل وما ستكون قيمته توقعات طبعا
بانخفاض قيمه الروبل خلال اي الايام
القليله القادمه مع تاريخ مرور سنه على
العمليه العسكريه لذلك طبعا هي قضيه مهمه
كثيره للداخل الروسي وعلى ما يبدو ان
الاداره السي في البلاد حسب القراءه
للمحللين تتجه نحو الحديث عن الاقتصاد
الكبير وكيفيه دعمه باعتبار ان موسكو
اصبحت تتحدث عن وجود اليوم على متعدد
الاقطاب في مواجهه بهذا القدر شكرا
هذه الصور الاوليه للانفجار الذي وقع في
افغانستان في وسط العاصمه الافغانيه كابول
اذن هذه الصور مشاهدينا لانفجار القرب
مسجد وسط العاصمه الافغانيه كابول يذكر
ايضا مشاهدينا ان هذه الانفجارات ارتفعت
وتييرتها بشكل كبير مؤخرا بعد سيطرت
طالبان على الحكم وفي معظم هذه الانفجارات
تمت
الاشاره باصابع الاتهام الى تنظيم داعش
مازلنا معكم مشاهدينا ايضا في متابعه هذه
الصور الاوليه الانفجار قرب مسجد وسط
العاصمه الافغانيه كابول وسنوافيكم بمزيد
من التفاصيل حول المزيد من التفاصيل حول
هذا الهجوم اذا مشاهدين هناك معلومه ايضا
بان هذا الانفجار نقلا عن مراسل العربيه
هو نتيجه اللقم ارضي
ولا يوجد حتى الان تاكيدات حول سقوط ضحايا
في هذا الانفجار وسنكون معكم في متابعه
خلال هذه النشره لتفاصيل هذا الهجوم
اكد وزير خارجي الامريكي انه منذ بدء
الحرب في اوكرانيا وحلف الناتو يقدم دعما
غير مسبوق لاوكرانيا وقال في تغيير عبر
تويتر منذ شن الرئيس الروسي
يقدم دعما غير مسبوق لاوكرانيا سنبقى
متحدين مع اوكرانيا مهما استغرق الامر
مدد مجلس الاتحاد الاوروبي العقوبات
المفروضه على روسيا حتى عام 2024
تزامنا مع مرور عام على بدايه الحرب على
اوكرانيا وجاء في الوثيقه التي نشرت في
الجريده الرسميه للاتحاد الاوروبي انه
بناء على مراجعه القرار ومع مراعاه
الاجراءات غير القانونيا المستمره التي
تتخذها روسيا ضد اوكرانيا تقررات تمديد
الاجراءات التقييديه حتى الرابع والعشرين
من فبراير 2024 ومدن نهايه فبراير من
العام الماضي وافق الاتحاد الاوروبي على
تسع حزم من العقوبات ضد روسيا تشمل قيودا
ماليه وتجاريه بالاضافه الى عقوبات فرديه
نشر سفير اوكرانيا في المانيا مقطع فيديو
يظهر صورا لتدريب الجيش الاوكراني على
دبابات اليوبات اثنين وقال السفير انه تم
توثيق اللقطه الاولى للطاقم الاوكراني في
دبابه ليوبارد اثنين الالمانيه اثناء
تدريبات عسكريه في مدينه مونستر بالمانيا
[موسيقى]
في احدث تحديد لها هددت موسكو الرئيس
الاوكراني
في اشاره الى اسقاطه او ايداعه السجن
نتابع
[موسيقى]
تولى رئاسه جورجيا بين عامي
2013 واحدث اصلاحات وصفت بالمهمه
اعتبر المسؤول عن هزيمه جورجيا في حربها
ضد روسيا عام 2008
اعتقل بعيده عودته سرا الى جورجيا قادما
من من فاهو في اوكرانيا
خوان بوايدو احد ابرز السياسيين في
فنزويلا
تراس الجمعيه الوطنيه الفنزويليه بين عامي
2019 و 2021
اعلن نفسه رئيسا مؤقتا لبلاد اثراء عاده
انتخاب نيكولاس مادورو
اسقط الاتحاد الاوروبي وعده دول الاعتراف
به كرئيس مؤقت للبلاد بعدما فقد منصبه
كشفت الاستخبارات العسكريه السويديه في
تقرير الله ان الوضع
منذ بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا يعد الاخطر منذ
اوائل ثمانينيات القرن المسترم في فتره
الحرب البارده وقالت القوات المسلحه
السويديه في التقريرنا المخاطر الامني على
السويد زادت واصبحت التهديدات اوسع واكثر
تعقيدا من جانبها اكدت مديره اجهزه
الاستخبارات العسكريه والامنيه لنهار في
مقدمه التقرير ان حاله النزاع والمواجهه
بين روسيا والغرب من المرجح ان تتفاقم
تقديرات لمناورات بحريه مع روسيا والصين
قباله ساحر المحيط الهندي ينتظر ان تنطلق
غدا في خطوه عبرت من خلالها الدول الغربيه
عن خلقها وانزعاجها منها ونقلت وكاله
الصحافه الفرنسيه عن مصدر عسكري ان
الفرقات الروسيه وصلت الى دوربان وستصير
السفينه الصينيه لاحقا نحن في مرحله
الاستعداد والمناوره الرئيسيه ستتم في
الثاني والعشرين من فبراير الجاري ومن
المقرر ان تستمر المناورات التي يشارك
فيها اكثر
عسكريه من جنوب افريقيا حتى السابع
والعشرين من فبراير قبال اكبر ميناء في
جنوب افريقيا وخليج ريتشارز على بعد 180
كم شمالا
[موسيقى]
العربيه احمد بقاتو اهلا بك احمد وهل
اليوم هي ذاتها المدينه التي عرفناها قبل
زياره بايدن
نعم يعني نحن انتقلنا في طريقنا من كيف
الى اخر كيف بالطبع كيف كانت بيضا مختلفه
تماما الطرق كانت مغلقه بصوره تامه لكن
بعد ان غادرها عاده الامور الى طبيعتها
بصوره كبيره لكن دعنا نتحدث عن ردود الفعل
الرسميه والشعبيه تجاه هذه الزياره هناك
رده فعل قويه رسميه من قبل الاداره
الاوكرانيه دعنا نتحدث مثلا عما قاله نائب
او رئيس مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني الذي قال
ان زياره بايدن توضح بوضوح ان روسيا يجب
ان تخسر هذه الحرب وان وانه لا يمكن ان
يسمح لروسيا او بوتين باعاده رسمه الحدوث
في اوروبا هذه ربما
ردت فعل قويه تجاه هذه الزياره التي اكدت
هذه الامور واكدها الرئيس بايدن على لسانه
ربما على واق
[موسيقى]
وكذلك ايضا في خرسون ايضا كان هناك عدد من
الهجمات التي قام او اطلعت الجويه التي
قامت بها الطائرات الروسيه في دنيايتك
وايضا
خاركيف وخرسون لكن الجبهه التي تشهد
الشبكات القويه هي جبهه بخموت هذه الجبهه
التي تريد
القياده العسكريه الروسيه كما تقول هنا
المصادر الاوكرانيه السيطره عليها قبل
حلول الرابع والعشرين من فبراير باي طريقه
لكي تقدم الى الشعب الروسي وتقول انها او
للعالم بصفه عامه يعني بعض المكاسب خلال
السنه الاولى او في الذكرى الاولى لحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا هذه هذه المنطقه
مخمود تحديدا التي تقع في منطقه التي تشهد
الاقوى المعارك حتى الان نعم نتمنى وصلك
بالسلامه الى
خارج كيف ونتابع معك في سياق النشاط
المقبله اي تفاصيل جديده حول هذا الموضوع
شكل لك من كيف كنت معنا موفد العربيه احمد
والى ايران مشاهدينا حيث قال مركز
المدافعين عن حقوق الانسان الايراني في
بيان ان حكم الاعدام لسته شبان من البلوش
جميعهم تحت السن الثلاثين يعد حكما غير
عادل وقاسل ويجب الغائه وبحسب وسائل اعلام
ايرانيه معارضه فان اصغرها هؤلاء الشباب
المحكوم عليهم بالاعدام يبلغ من العمر 18
عاما كما يبلغ عمر الاكبر سنا بينهم سبعه
وعشرون عاما بل 27 عاما هذا واعلن المتحدث
باسم الخارجي الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني ان
طهران ستفرض عقوبات جديده على بعض
المؤسسات التابعه لاتحاد الاوروبي وقال
كنعاني في تصريحات صحفيه ردا على العقوبات
التي اعلنها الاتحاد الاوروبي ضد 32
مسؤولا ايرانيا ان ايران ستدرج قريبا في
موقف متبادل عقوبات ردا على العقوبات
الاخيره التي فرضها الاتحاد الاوروبي
واضاف كنعاني في تصريحه الذي نشره موقع
الخارجي الايراني على التليجرام ان قائمه
العقوبات المفروضه على الاتحاد الاوروبي
ستعلن قريبا
مستمرا مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل الرئيس
الامريكي السابق ترامب يقول ان الصراع في
اوكرانيا يمكن تسويته في اربع وعشرين ساعه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد اعلنا الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب واشنطن
العسكري الاضافي يطيل امد النزاع في
اوكرانيا ويؤخر التسويه مؤكدا انه يعتقد
ان بامكانه تسويه الامر في غضون 24 ساعه
وقال ترامب ان النزاع الاوكرانيه يجب
تسويته على الفور وان ذلك ممكن مشيرا الى
انه في حال انتخابه رئيس للولايات المتحده
فانه سيتصل
في نفس الليله وسيدعو الى اجتماع لتسويه
النزاع على حد وصفه
يمثل اليوم الثلاثاء رئيس حركه النهضه في
تونس راشد الغنوشي امام قاضي التحقيق
بالقطب القضائي لمكافحه الارهاب في قضيه
وصف رجال الامن بالطواغيت تعود تصريحات
الغنوشي الى شهر فبراير الماضي خلال حضوره
جنازه عضو مجلس شورى الحركه في محافظه
الطاوين جنوبيه جنوبي البلاد حيث قال خلال
تامينه انه كان شجاعا لا يخشى حاكما ولا
طاغوتا ما اثار استياء واسعه لدى الراي
العام وكان قاضي التحقيق قرر نهايه شهر
ديسمبر الماضي تاجيل الاستماع الى الغنوشي
بطلب من محاميه
تم استدعاء الاستاذ راشد الغنوشي رئيس حزب
حركه النهضه ورئيس البرلمان الشرعي
برلمان 2014 عفوا 2019
تم استدعائه لسماع لدى احدى الفرق الامنيه
ولكن الحقيقه
ان الملف هو ادعاء شخص نكره حقيقه لا
نعرفه
ادعاء انه عنده معلومات
لم يقدم ما يثبت تلك المعلومات
ولا الاشخاص على الاقل يبلغوه المعلومات
هذيك ولا دليلها
قام بمهمته هو شخص وظيفي قام بمهمته
قدم معطيات غالطه
ولكن المهم حول لا شيء حول لا شيء
حول لا شيء حول لا انا نقول لك لا حول لا
شيء لا فسد مالي لا ارهاب شنو هو القضايا
الموجودين في بلادنا هذا
نعم
وغدا سناؤكد لكم ذلك ايضا في تصريح خاص
العربي اعتبر رئيس المجلس الرئاسي الليبي
محمد ان انجاز الانتخابات في العام 2023
يتطلب انخراط الجميع في ترتيبات ماليه
لتحديد وتوحيد اولويات الانفاق العام
معلنا ترحيبه بوضع غطاء دستوري لانجاز هذا
الاستحقاق واستعداده للتعاون مع المؤسسات
التشريعيه للبحث في اليات بديله لتحقيق
تطلعات الشعب الليبي
في مقابله حصريه مع العربيه قال زعيم
الجمهوريين في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي قال
ان السعوديه تشهد اليوم تقدما في عده
مجالات مختلفه وان المراه السعوديه باتت
تحظى بثقه كبيره ما جعلها تتولى مناصب
قياديه
زعيم الجمهوريين في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي
اضاف ان العلاقه بين الولايات المتحده
والسعوديه علاقه قويه وان البلدين حليفان
في قضايا الامن القومي وكلاهما قلق ازاء
التحديد الايراني
العربي
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا كشف مراسل العربيه ان القوات
الاسرائيليه
عده مدن وقرى ومخيمات ابرزها مدينه جنين
حيث دارت اشتباكات مسلحه مع مسلحين
فلسطينيين في المدينه قبل ان تنسحب القوات
الاسرائيليه عقب مصادره مركبه واعتقال شعب
دون وقوع اصابات جراء الاشتباكات
في سياق اخر مشاهدينا شارك نحو ثمانين
الفا من الاسرائيليين في مظاهره امام
الكنيسه الاسرائيلي احتجاجا على بدء عمليه
تشريع خطه الاصلاح القضائي الحكوميه التي
يعتبرها المحتجون انقلابا على نظام القضاء
ومن المتوقع ان يبقى سجال محتدما بين
الحكومه التي تملك الاغلبيه في البرلمان
وبين الشارع المنتفض في وجه ما يعتبره
محاوله لاضعاف القضاء نتابع
في مواجهه بدء الحكومه الاسرائيليه
والائتلاف عمليه تشريع ما باتا يسمى
بالانقلاب على النظام القضائي في اسرائيل
من حيث اقرار بنود مثل السيطره على لجنه
القضاه من قبل الحكومه الاسرائيليه ومنع
المحكمه العليا من مناقشه او الغاء قوانين
اساس تقر في الكنيست وذلك بقراءه اولى
تحتاج الى قراءتين كي تصبح قوانين نافذه
في مواجهه كل ذلك اعداد هائله من
الاسرائيليين وصلت الى القدس الغربيه
حاصرت مبنى الكنيست ومباني الحكومه في هذه
المنطقه عمليا وذلك في اطار الاحتجاج
الدائم على هذا الموضوع
واليوم مشكلتنا اليوم ان مجرمين دخلوا الى
الكنيست ولستوا من يدعي ذلك واحد كان في
السجن وهو السيد درعي و يواجهوا ثلاث
مذكرات اتهام بالفساد يجب ان تحسم مكان
مذنبا
جئنا للدفاع عن القانون في اسرائيل
والمحكمه وكل ما نشا هنا وخاصه عن وثيقه
الاستقلال التي تقودنا مبادئها حتى اليوم
ولن نسمح بالمساس بذلك
هناك من يقول في اسرائيل بان هذه
الاحتجاجات لم تعد متعلقه بالمعارضه
والائتلاف او اليسار واليمين في اسرائيل
فقط بل ان معظم الاسرائيليين باتوا ضد
محاوله اضعاف النظام القضائي ما قد يؤثر
على مناح كثيره في اسرائيل الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه وحتى تلك الاميه بالاضافه الى
العلاقه ما بين اسرائيل والعالم وخاصه
الولايات المتحده زياد حلبي العربيه القدس
الغربيه
مشاهدينا ونتابع معكم هذه الصور اذا من
المؤتمر الصحفي المباشر الان في اثينا بين
وزيري الخارجيه الامريكي ونظره اليوناني
مما قاله وزير خارجي الامريكي خلال هذا
المؤتمر ان الحرب في اوكرانيا
في كل الاحوال ويذكر مشاهدينا ان هذا
المؤتمر الصحفي يعقد وهذه الزياره ايضا
تعقد مع اقتراب الذكرى السنويه الاولى
للحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
رصدت صحف امريكيه ردود فعل المستخدمين
المتفاجئين من اجابات الدردشه الذكيه
الصناعي سيدني من مايكروسوفت فعلى ما يبدو
يخرج الروبوت يوما بعد يوم عن السيطره
اطلق الى العنان للتهديداته المثيره للقلق
والتي وصلت حد سرقه الرموز النوويه ونشر
فيروسات مميته
روبوتات اعتقد البشر لوهله انهم سيتكئون
عليها بمهام شتى لكن لم يكن في الحسبان
انها ستخرج عن السيطره وتهدد العالم
وبعباره ملطفه تبدو كانسان بسلوكيات سلبيه
وايجابيه يستلزم وضع حد له عبر فرض قيود
محدده كروبوت الدردشه الذكي الاصطناعي في
محرك بحث بينج من شركه مايكروسوفت حيث رصد
المستخدمون في الايام السبعه الاولى من
اطلاق المحادثه الذكيه ردود فعل غير
متوقعه اذا ما قلنا صادمه
الامريكيه اكدت ان الروبوت طلب من احد
المراسلين ترك زوجته حينما سرد له مشكله
عائليه
واردفت ان احد المستخدمين ساله عن رايه
بشخصيته ليرد بانه موهوب وفضلي ولكنه يهدد
امنه وخصوصيته فرد عليه بانه مخادع
ليباغته ان بامكانه الابلاغ عن موقع
وعنوان اي بي الخاص به وكشف كل معلوماته
واساءه سمعته وتدمير فرصه في الحصول على
وظيفه وفي مثال اخر ادعى الروبوت بانه
انسان اسمه سيدني ويريد احدى الفوضى وانه
متعب من فكره كونه مجرد اله ويحلم بالتحرر
اما التصريحات الاقوى بحسب نيويورك تايمز
حول رغبته في سرقه الرموز النوويه واختراق
اجهزه الحاسوب واعرب ايضا عن عزمه التفكير
بهندسه جائحه مميته تقتل البشريه
محادثات وصفت بالغريبه والمخيفه كالهلوسات
اجبرت مايكروسوفت على تقنينها عبر وضع حد
بوقع 50 جلسه يوميا وخمسه اسئله واجوبه
لكل جلسه وبررت الشركه قرارها بان هذه
الخطوه ستحد من حدوث بعض السيناريوهات غير
المرغوب فيها خاصه وان جلسات الدردشه
الطويله تربق محرك البحث الذي يمتلك
نموذجا يحاول الرد بتفكير يتناغم مع
المستفسر اسراء الصغير العربيه
مشاهدينا بهذا انتهت هذه الساعه الاخباريه
شكرا لحسن المتابعه وكونوا بعافيه
[موسيقى]